the first US National Security Advisor
John Bolton is set to depart turkey
without having met with President wretch
of type air dawuan the two were expected
to discuss the fate of the Kurds allied
with the United States in Syria as part
of wider discussions about the US troop
withdrawal from the country earlier
Bolton said that Ankara must guarantee
the safety of the Kurds before
Washington pulled out the Turkish
president slammed Bolton over his
comments and called them unacceptable
[Music]
regarding this matter Bolton has made a
serious mistake and whoever thinks like
this has also made a mistake it is not
possible for us to make compromises on
this point those who are part of the
terror corridor in Syria will receive
the necessary lesson there is no single
difference between the PKK YPG PYD and -
now during the course of the war in
Syria Kurdish forces most importantly
the YPG that we just heard air21
mentioned they managed to gain control
over a large area bordering with Turkey
they have successfully fought back the
so-called Islamic state with support
from the United States but Ankara does
not accept them as representatives of
the Kurdish people and regards them as a
terror organization because of their
ties to Turkey's outlawed Kurdistan
Workers Party the PKK let's get more on
the story DWS Dorian Jones has the
latest from Istanbul so Dorian how are
we to interpret these statements is this
a deliberate snub of a senior trump aid
by the Turkish president well prisoner
the ones refusal to meet with Bolton he
insisted wasn't a deliberate snub he
said that the Bolton had met with
Turkey's defense minister and his
spokesman and that would it be entirely
sufficient but given what heard one has
said into his parliamentary deputies
today a very strong language attacking
Bolton everyone his ceases as a direct
snob to Bolton and according to Turkish
media reports Bolton is cutting
his visit to Ankara further evidence
that this is being seen as a major
setback in u.s. Turkish relations and
president air21 also apparently
insisting that he actually has an
agreement with President Trump to take
action against Kurdish forces I just
want to have a listen to what he said on
that front and then get your reaction
Dorian in compliance with the agreement
we reached with mr. president we have
largely completed our preparations for a
military offensive against elements of -
who are still active in Syria at the
same time we are determined to take
steps against terrorist organizations
such as PYD and YPG along with - we will
mobilize to neutralize these terrorist
organizations in Syria lands very soon
so some some looming statements there
Dorian what do you think very soon means
in this context what well I think that's
what everyone will be asking Turkey is
continuing to masses forces all along
the Syrian border across from where the
Syrian Kurdish militia are based and
also where US forces are still deployed
now now it seems that the original
feeling was that following our Trump's
commitment to immediately withdraw US
soldiers that had prevented an imminent
operation now that we've drawn is in
doubt following Bolton's visit it seems
that anything is now possible although
it has to be said we are getting reports
within the Turkish military High Command
there are big reservations about
launching an operation in winter and
it's when US forces are still deployed
bringing the risk of a possible clash
between the two NATO allies something
that both sides really would be keen to
avoid and that would also carry the risk
of financial implications turkish lira
is very vulnerable any major rift or new
crisis with the US could see a major
depreciation in the currency as well so
these are major factors for other one to
weigh up in this decision to launch an
imminent operation into Syria how likely
do you see the possibility that he will
indeed launch that operation risk a
breach with President Trump and really
go against the Kurds
in Syria well I think that President
earth one is putting all of his analysis
and decisions on his relationship with
Trump this deal to withdraw from the
Syria by US forces was hatched following
a conversation between President Erdogan
and president Trump heard one is
underlined he says that he sees this as
a deal with Trump and we'll be looking
to Trump what he says on its side of the
deal and I think that the narrative
we're getting from Unger is the problem
isn't with trumpets with these the
ministers and key ministers around Trump
that is where the problem lies
third one still believes if he can talk
with Trump he can deescalate and end
this potential crisis but if Trump does
backtrack third one could well feel
cornered and feel he would have to carry
out this operation especially as there
are critical local elections in the next
2-3 months appearing weak to the United
States doesn't play well with Turkish
voters Dorian Jones in Istanbul
thank you Dorian
you